genre musique
un dimanche matin
sur l'ancienne place d'armes de berlin
où s'exerçait jadis l'armée prussienne
le personnel d'une usine une parmi tant
d'autres organise ses propres aux
olympiades ex comme l usine jeunes moins
jeunes cultivent cette vertu dont la rda
a le secret performance
le sport est non seulement le loisir
numéro un
il est ici une seconde nature au fond ce
n'est peut-être que cela la clé de la
réussite de cette république
démocratique allemande
troisième puissance mondiale du sport
après les états unis et l'union
soviétique
nous arrivons au siège de l'office du
sport en herbe et à un véritable
ministère
le sport en rdr est il une véritable
organisation de masse ou bien comme
certains le disent le prétend une
industrie des médailles
je voudrais dire tout d'abord qu'il n'y
a pas chez nous d'industrie les
médailles concept maintenir le sport
chez nous une très large base populaire
2 millions 400 mille personnes sont
membres les associations sportives 2
rbds et 1
prises dans leur ensemble cela signifie
que 14,2 pour cent de la population
ça donne objectivement au score soit un
citoyen de notre état lorsque vous posez
cette question serait d'industrie des
médailles je dirais qu'il faut chercher
l'explication de nos bons résultats
naturellement dans cette base de masse
du sport chez nous et en particulier
tout d'abord dans ce large mouvement
sportif de la jeunesse et de l'enfance
grâce au parti de la classe ouvrière
grâce au parti socialiste unifié
d'allemagne grâce au gouvernement de la
rda
ce mouvement reçoit tout le soutien
voulu et tous les jeunes talents en
matière de sport seront systématiquement
découvert et développé ses jeunes
talents
comment les les couvre au ton très
simple
c'est le système du tamis les meilleurs
nécessairement resteront à la surface
ils n'ont aucune chance de passer à
travers les mailles cet immense filet
que constituent les spartak yade s'est
faite de la jeunesse du sport
chaque année sur la base de l'école du
centre d'apprentissage du bureau de
l'usiné sont organisées à travers toute
la république
ces fameuses spartak yade en quelque
sorte une vaste pré sélection si vous
voulez les primaires du sport national
tous les deux ans des spartak yade
centrale c'est leur nom sélectionnerons
les meilleures d'entre les meilleurs à
l'échelon du pays et le moindre geste
sportif le moindre des efforts seront
accomplis et penser en fonction de ce
but et spartak yade préliminaire à tout
olympiades futur ce qui se passe après
après la découverte est beaucoup moins
de public d'entraînement de haut niveau
est top secret pas question de filmer
cette piscine protégé comme un objectif
militaire
alors allez savoir lorsqu'en 72 à munich
j'ai eu l'honneur de porter notre
drapeau dans le stade
représentant une équipe souveraine j'ai
naturellement ressenti une très grande
fierté parce que nous soyons parvenus à
cela la fierté nationale
le désir d'affirmation de soi même comme
république à part entière après tant
d'années de persévérance voilà sans
doute un autre ressort de leur réussite
le sport moyen privilégié de promotion
sociale et d'évasion est une vertu
cardinale de la politique officielle
selon l'adage que voici en bonne santé
préparer aux performances heureux de
vivre est optimiste pour la paix et le
socialisme faisons tous du sport